[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 22nd
of June
2023 my name is Freddie gray I am the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host today
coming up this week we will be talking
about the crushing reality of the
mortgage crisis it's not good news but
it is the cover piece written by Kate
Andrews about the fact that with
interest rates Rising they're expected
to rise again today we don't quite yet
know by how much uh people homeowners
people with mortgages are going to
suffer increasingly and it's merging
into quite a serious crisis for this
government and another opportunity for
the labor party
I'll be talking to Kate Andrews our
economics editor and our data nerd
Michael Simmons
after that I will be talking to our
politics editor Katie Bulls about the
week in Westminster and further afield
and then we'll be talking about America
and the Curious story of Hunter Biden
who this week seems to have accepted a
plea deal
um which will mean he is not going to
face any time in jail but he will be
found guilty of relatively minor
offenses what's going on there it all
seems rather fishy to fill us in I'll be
joined by Charles Lipson professor
Charles Lipson of the University of
Chicago
after that we will move on to a rather
morbid topic which is the story of
stairways falling out of airplanes and
landing in Sheen often Frozen uh it's
Grim stuff but I'll be joined by the
wonderful Louise Perry the author and
broadcaster to talk about a piece she's
written on the subject in the magazine
this week
and finally Cricket this week we had the
end of the first test match in this
year's ashes and it was a thriller I'm
delighted to say we're going to be
joined by Henry blofeld the great great
Cricket commentator to talk about the
ashes and this famous word bazball
before we get into all of that I would
like to remind you to subscribe to
spectator TV uh you can do that by
clicking the Subscribe button at the
bottom of your screen and after that if
you click the Bell icon you'll get a
reminder every time a new episode is
available to watch
uh I'd also like to thank very
importantly our sponsors the brilliant
canacore genuity wealth management who
supports this show and we're very
grateful to them Canna called R of
course as you should know by now if
you've been watching experience wealth
managers and investment managers who
offer unwavering support in these
challenging times visit can do
wealth.com
for more information first up mortgages
I will waive the cover of The Spectator
again the camera home truths is the
cover piece and it's written by Kate
Andrews and it is about the crushing
reality there's some people being
crushed if you can see uh the crushing
reality of the mortgage crisis which is
really the story of the week at least in
Britain I'm also joined by data editor I
called you data nerd I should not have
done Michael's data editor Michael
Simmons yeah he respond to both uh but
Kate uh excellent cover piece
um it's a bit of a sort of boiled frog
this isn't it because if we remember
back you started on the Liz trust mini
budget and how the fear and panic about
what was going to happen to interest
rates uh back then and the shared level
of political crisis it's called We're
actually in a worse position now aren't
we quite possibly so the last time we
were talking about a mortgage crisis was
last Autumn and when the mini budget
triggered huge expectations around how
High interest rates would rise and we
were talking about people not being able
to pay their mortgage and when Jeremy
Hunt came in the chancellor he rolled
back almost all of that mini budget and
the markets calmed down but last
December he held a sort of mortgage
Summit uh and I think at the time you
know this this was not a big piece of
the news agenda but the numbers that
came out of it are really quite
startling
the financial conduct Authority at the
time calculated that 500 000 people
might struggle to pay their mortgage
under what was happening with Liz truss
and since Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunter
come in and made changes that was
lowered to about 350 000. uh Jeremy Hunt
looked at that figure and thought wow
that's still too high and frankly the
worst may still be to come because
wealth interest rates and and and them
Rising were no longer being triggered by
fiscal decisions the tough reality is
that rates were going up all over the
world he expected that they would
continue to rise and the situation was
only going to get progressively worse at
a slower Pace in which hopefully you can
maybe do something but you know this was
just going to be a tough reality so at
the time he he kind of used that as a
foundation as a framework to potentially
bring in some regulatory reforms to help
people with their mortgages and that's
exactly what the government is looking
at now speaking to lenders about moving
people they're having enough if they're
having a tough time to interest-only
payments looking at payment holidays
things like that but they're ruling out
subsidies they're ruling out support and
I think what's interesting this week as
we saw now the average two-year fixed
term mortgage hit six percent is that
you have even Tory MPS saying we must do
something and that has been the
catchphrase of the past three years
around covid furlough we must do
something around the energy crisis we
need subsidies I think this is the first
real test in which the government feels
it can say no feels it must say no and
is saying no but this is a political
headache for the Tory party because if
we're talking about mortgage holders and
homeowners we're talking about people
who are disproportionately likely voting
Tori so it's it's politically difficult
but this idea of of subsidies is
completely ruled out as I said right now
anyway as I say in the piece I'm one
treasury Insider basically says those
ideas are Dead on Arrival they're really
going to try to stick to this well labor
it's all over the papers today are
pushing their sort of mortgage crisis
Solutions but they seem quite similar to
the governments don't they I haven't
seen anything different it's just being
said with a bit more oomph
um and I suppose from a political
perspective if you're an opposition
that's exactly what you would do you say
the government isn't doing enough you
would repeat a lot of their talking
lines but make it sound different and
you wouldn't commit yourself to anything
because what can labor commit itself to
I mean gosh if they actually started to
say like we'll step in
um you know you'd be questioning Central
Bank Independence on interest rates you
would be talking about subsidies for
mortgage holders it would be you know I
think catastrophic politically for them
to actually try to come up with
Solutions the tough reality here is that
there aren't that many solutions this is
the market reaction to the huge amount
of money printing that happened world
over we have to tackle inflation
interest rates were held at an ultra low
level for decades they are now Rising as
a note in the piece to historically
normal rates these are not especially
High interest rates but people aren't
used to it it is really painful we can
have a lot of empathy for that but at
the same time you know this is this is a
real test to politicians to say look
this isn't a war this isn't a pandemic
this is a market reaction a tough one
um and you know we we can't really
intervene all that much but it may be it
may be not very good economics but
there's a strong political will and
there may be a good case that the banks
can actually take a bit of pain here uh
given that the government has helped the
banking sector quite a lot uh in recent
years well that's what I think the
government this week is speaking to
lenders about they've been using quite
tough language about how lenders have a
responsibility to those who have taken
out mortgages to help them as much as
possible but the housing market overall
is so distorted in this country if you
start distorting it further to help
people who are already on the housing
ladder I think another thing in the back
of the mind to politicians is how are
renters going to respond to that because
rents have been skyrocketing with
inflation renters are having a really
tough time and if you start you know
going above and beyond to help mortgage
holders that's another kind of political
headache Michael I've got it struck uh
that
um this crisis hasn't already got that
bad because I'd have thought already a
lot of people would be defaulting is
there evidence that people are
defaulting in large numbers yet so
defaults are definitely up and we've
actually seen quarter and quarter
there's a 50 rise in like actual
repossessions but the numbers are still
quite small and that's because of the
way the mortgage Market is kind of
structured in the UK a lot of people
um are coming up to the end of their
two-year fix or they're on a longer
they're maybe on a five-year fix and
they've not come up to that
renegotiation re-deal stage yet but
there was one estimate that by the end
of this year there's going to be another
1.3 million people who are going to have
to renegotiate so the problem is going
to get worse but it's because people are
still on these deals that we haven't
seen it yet but it's definitely coming
down the line and because
um a lot of the newer mortgages are on
the two-year fixes it's kind of
affecting younger people more as well
first-time buyers more so it's the
problem is stored up in the system and
unless rates go down quickly which no
one expects them to then the problem you
know is still coming at us quite a
common and fair complaint among
consumers and mortgage holders and
Savers is that yes mortgage rates are
going up but interest rates have not
been going up for Savers yeah banks are
not offering competitive is that
starting to happen now are banks
beginning to offer attractive interest
rate so they are improving their their
offering and there are some better rates
that you can get from Banks especially
some of the kind of more competitive
um ones on the market but there's still
it's that huge gap and and certainly
banks are going to want to make a profit
and that is one of the ways they make
that profit and so I think you there's
there's calls for the banks to do more
to um increase their attractiveness for
Savers and but it's it's nowhere near
the the rates that they're charging on
these mortgages and Loans okay
um always attractive or to gloomsters
like myself it's always attractive to
think that this is going to be a sort of
financial apocalypse uh it does though
have the potential to dwarf 2008 uh as a
financial crisis if we start to see
large-scale defaults on mortgages
potentially but if Watchers want to go
over to our podcast after they finish
spectator TV on the Edition Liam
Halligan who writes for the Telegraph
and covers economics on GP news makes a
quite strong case as to why we're not in
financial crash territory that the banks
are in a much much better situation than
they were over a decade ago now and
rather than this being a financial crash
kind of scenario it's more a very
painful and rude awakening for people
who bought towards the top of their
budget because they never thought
interest rates would budge and are now
discovering that actually they can't
afford the property that they bought now
that doesn't have to be catastrophic
necessarily but it can prove very
painful especially if at some point you
were downsizing and you know and having
to take rather Extreme Measures I think
the difficulty is that as we go into
2024 you're just going to have this drip
drip drip of people who are coming up
for Renewal it's estimated that between
now and the end of the year that'll be
1.3 and million mortgage holders you
know it's certainly not the bulk of
mortgage holders but it's a quite
substantial number and in the best case
scenario you're going to be afraid and
in the worst case scenario you're
actually going to be saying I I can't
afford this and neither is a good
position for the government to be going
into an election year and then on top of
that you have the fact that interest
rates are rising people are feeling the
crunch of that inflation's still really
really high and you know this is where I
point the finger at the bank of England
which was so slow to reactorizing
inflation interest rates are the best
tool we have to get that down but when
they're implemented so late in the game
and inflation's already spiraling you're
never going to get the full effect of
that interest rate so rates are rising
we're feeling the crunch of that they're
not fully tackling inflation as we can
see I mean core inflation we discovered
this week is still actually Rising it's
not sticky or stubborn it's going in the
wrong direction and so we're feeling the
pain of both it's making us all feel a
lot poorer it's eating away at our
disposable income inflation and I don't
see a scenario going into next year
where anybody feels all that better off
um the case from the government will be
well you know we took the hard choices
we're trying to get ourselves on the
path to Prosperity labor keeps saying
they want to spend all this money that's
inflationary but it's going to certainly
be difficult to make the case I think
especially for someone like Rishi sunak
who came in with this idea that I'll do
the hard stuff I'll hike taxes but that
will help protect people's mortgage
payments that will get things under
control
things do feel much more under control
now these are small and slow changes but
they're adding up to as you said at the
start Freddy a worse situation for some
people again not really driven by fiscal
policy but by the fact that we've ended
this era of cheap money we've entered a
new one and there's nothing that any
politician can do about that well
there's a sense of control in the sense
that people think that Jeremy Huntsman
machine responsible people but to a
large extent a lot of this problem
Michael you can do some cake trip into a
lot of this problem relate comes from
rishisu next time as Chancellor and the
enormous amount of furlough money pumped
into the economy uh I think the
government spent up to a trillion pounds
is it the best part of a trillion pounds
over the past three years it was what
350 billion in 2020. yeah and I think
and Kate mentions in her piece that
there was a point where the bank was
printing money you know almost as fast
as the government could spend it yeah
and um sunak you know is kind of lauded
for being one of of the people like Kate
who predicted inflation and said you
know these things are going to happen
but at the same time sunak was the
person that did this as Chancellor yeah
and I mean obviously the bank of England
is responsible for printing the money
but sunac then later on the furlough
scheme it's easy to predict inflation if
you print almost a trillion pounds well
exactly
it wasn't that much it wasn't that much
but it wasn't that much and and I didn't
predict inflation that's very kind I
just wrote about people who did
um but I look I I think it's an
interesting point Fred because as you
say I think we printed more money in
2020 than we did in every year leading
up to the financial crash from 2010 but
it's not money printing Kate it's not
you're not supposed to say money
printing you're supposed to say
quantitative easing
um it's it's an important point I I
think and the defense of uh Rishi
sinakis Chancellor is that something
like the furlough scheme was actually
quite free market in nature the idea
behind it was we're forcing you to stay
at home but the second we allow you back
out we can reopen the economy and get
things back to home when you won't have
lost your job that was supposed to be if
you remember a couple of weeks
it ends it up that scheme running gosh
until mid-2021 September 2021 I mean
that scheme was extended and extended
and used by the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson at the time to keep us in
lockdown because it was a way of
justifying it now I'm not saying that
Chancellor rishikinak doesn't deserve
like a lot of the responsibility that
comes with the decisions that were made
but that was always the standoff between
Boris Johnson and Richie sunak is where
she kept saying we're spending too much
money this is inflationary and Boris
Johnson said I want to have my cake and
eat it
um uh so but look every every Advanced
economy is dealing with this problem
in the UK however we are becoming an
outlier on inflation I think a lot of
that again does come back to the central
bank which just did not tackle it fast
enough but a lot of that further cash as
well is still kind of dampening the
bank's tools to get inflation down
because a lot of people who were maybe
better off in the pandemic saved that
for a low cash and just generally had
less less outgoing so they're relying on
savings now which is why that the bank
is kind of failing to get consumption
down which is partly why core inflation
which you can't blame on Ukraine you
can't blame on Energy prices is still
shooting up well it's a very odd Paradox
isn't it because you've got a cost of
living crisis which people are feeling
the pain of you've got mortgage rates
going up and yet you've got consumer
spending still very strong isn't it yeah
Oxford economics estimates that people's
Savings in total now is somewhere
between six to 12 percent of overall GDP
in the UK it's absolutely massive and
they estimate that that was really
accumulated in 2021. this is Coveted
money and as that again drip drip drips
out into the real economy everyone's
been so shocked like how are interest
rates going up and people are still
quite confident to spend now it takes a
long time for interest rates to work
their way into the system and to be felt
but there is clearly so much money
sloshing around still and you know that
that means that these inflationary
pressures these underlying pressures are
still very persistent
Kate and Michael thank you very much
indeed now we've talked a little bit
about the political implications of
interest rates and mortgages in crisis
uh let's talk a bit more about politics
and the week in Westminster with our
delightful politics editor Katie Bulls
who has written a column this week in
The Spectator I'm going to hold it up
again
uh very good column uh highly recommend
you read it called can labor win back
Scotland
uh okay just we'll get to Scotland in a
bit but first we should probably talk
about the big news at the beginning of
the week which was the banishment
surprise surprise shock horror of Boris
Johnson from Parliament it nobody was
surprised with it no I didn't even Boris
Johnson was surprised he almost wanted
it yes and this was almost a spillover
from the drama of last week which was of
course
um well stretching actually Beyond last
week but um the fact that Boris Johnson
has quit the commons the publication of
the Privileges report uh which uh I
think to very few people's surprise uh
found him guilty of intentionally
misleading Parliament to also a few
people's surprise Boris Johnson does not
accept the findings and this is all
heading up to what lots of people
thought last week I think would be quite
a fiery debate and vote
um now because Boris Johnson quit the
commons there was no vote to matter he
should be suspended he has ultimately
made his own decision to go to avoid
that instead it came down to whether or
not Boris Johnson should be allowed the
House of Commons pass that former MPS
are entitled to so you can freely come
and go on the houses of Parliament and
the committee said if we can't suspend
him we want to ban him from this now I
think technically Boris Johnson can
still enter Parliament if you just find
someone else with a Lobby pass a
parliament pass perhaps a colleague and
goes a visitor but he cannot off his own
accord straight around now this was the
punishment that MPS voted on it
unanimously passed only six Dory MPS
voted against the Privileges committee
and and this punishment and
that's clearly a very small number I
think Boris Johnson uh clearly knew
which way the wind was blowing so the
end of last week A Faculty made clear to
his supporters that they should not
fight the punishment
um suggesting that we all need to move
on I think this is in part because if
you think back to the Windsor framework
vote on Russia's student acts
renegotiated protocol deal Boris Johnson
made very clear he was going to oppose
it so did Liz trust and then it was
actually a little bit embarrassing for
both of them and so few MPS followed it
through and you know you look like a
marching around at the hill and then
actually there's not many there so so by
suggesting he didn't want anyone to vote
for him
um I think he can now say well actually
it's because it's because I told him not
to that's only six people yes and a lot
of Tories think that they can now move
on from the psychodrama of the Boris
years and kind of regain their footing
as a party and as a government
um but there's by-elections coming up
there's economic crisis it's not a
pretty picture for the Tories at the
moment particularly these by-elections
yeah I issues Lots were decently
and what are they moving to because as
you point to Freddie it doesn't look
particular particularly positive the
next chapter for the Tory party and I
think it's fair to say that Boris
Johnson's support speaking to those who
used to be very loyal to him is very
small right now in the House of Commons
so I think you could still get waves of
infighting obviously Boris Johnson has
his new column in the mail and though
the suggestions it won't be very
political but let's see how things go
with time weight loss was the sort of
yeah exam pick yeah have you tried it no
but I thought I might after um and
thanks for suggesting that I should uh I
thought I might after uh after reading
the column I don't think you'd fit in
the category to be fair um
yes I think that um therefore it's still
the case uh that you know Boris Johnson
and his remaining supporters can cause
racist index and problems but as you
point to the bigger problem is the
by-elections of Boris Johnson gave us a
leaving gift
um note to Rishi sunak and his
constituency in Nigel Adams and in
Nadine Doris should she ever actually
officially resign she's still um
technically an MP he was notably wasn't
in the vote
um on Monday despite all her defending
on Boris Johnson and but has not moved
in a way where they can actually call
the by-election yet and you also have
another MP David Warburton uh this week
uh he was quit and he's already been
suspended by the party but therefore
it's another uh by-election so we have
at least three by-elections on the 20th
of July and it means that people can say
all they like about how Boris Johnson is
no more and I think a comeback at least
in the near future is very unlikely but
his my elections will still I think hurt
Rishi neck in terms of just confirming
the political level is pretty bad for
the Tories I think at this point as they
managed to hold at least one actually be
very surprised and perhaps so she said
that's got more more to give
um but it's just gonna another problem
for if she see now but as you say in the
column there's perhaps a more I mean I
think looks like Victoria's going to
lose those by-elections there's a more
interesting perhaps uh by election
coming up in Scotland which might tell
us a little bit more about how this
election the next election will play out
exactly because right now you have three
to four by-elections of Tories will be
defending
um which we I think it's quite pricing
they'll probably lose all of those I
think at a general election
um the tourists think they would win at
least two of those back even on current
so mid bedfordshire pretty safe tour
easy in a by-election you get much more
of an anti-tory vote
um and potentially also Selby no
you have a such but so therefore I think
that the by-election will just confirm
we already know about uh current
anti-tory feeling
there's a more interesting in my view by
election which could be happening which
involves Margaret Ferrier who is smpmp
and she was suspended by the party
um for uh traveling when she had covered
it was around the time she has since
been suspended from the commons and
because the punishment was over 10
sitting days
um it means that there's now a record
petition and if you have enough names
sign up so it's 10 of the constituency a
by-election will follow now the Tories
technically don't really have any skin
in the game here it would be Scottish
labor trying to win back the seat from
the SMP and but if Scottish labor can
overturn it I think it will just um give
us a real sense of well this this
Scottish labor comeback we keep hearing
about is as strong as people say there
is an interesting panel-based survey
recently which suggested that actually
uh The Misfortune of the SMP in terms of
Nicholas sturgeon arrest uh also I think
um some many policy issues means that
you're now in a situation whereby
Scottish labor projected to be the
largest party but in Scotland by the
time of the next election and now that
would be very significant because when
you think about all of Labor's problems
the collapse of support in Scotland in
2015 and is one of the reasons they have
found it so hard to recover and you
speak to ministers uh talking about the
Scottish labor recovery and they will
say Kirsten is the luckiest politician
around because if there is a Scottish
labor recovery it makes it much easier
for kirstama to get a majority and in
the leader's office I think it's seen as
effectively the difference between a
hung Parliament and a majority and if if
Kirsten is the luckiest politician uh it
might be that Rishi sunak is is being
pretty unlucky because this is just
another thing that's falling against it
yes exactly and you know speaking to
Southern government this week and it's
almost become a bit of a joke now this
narrow path to Tory Victory
um because we heard it was very narrow
at the start of the year they're
speaking to one thing and say it's
getting narrower and narrower and you're
starting to imagine this path with uh
perhaps you know locusts coming at those
walking on it there's a fire at the end
um and I think it's just adding to this
sense which is what is the event that
could change uh the mood music and the
standing of the Tory party ahead of the
next election the biggest issue I think
is of course the economy as you're
talking about elsewhere in the show and
but it's looking hard for him she's
unite nothing is impossible in politics
it's just it's very very very narrow
Katie Forbes who had some admirers in
The Spectator office uh if she had won
the leadership which she very nearly did
uh do you think the Tories have been a
better position because labor would be
more threatened would you be a better
leader than
yeah I think it's funny in the sense the
Tories were delighted when Nicholas
sturgeon resigned and saw the s p as a
big threat to them but they almost want
the SMP to do badly but not so badly
that labor do incredibly well and
therefore I think that if you did have
Kate Forbes
um that could have helped in the sense
that she is someone who think would be
uh probably more likely to stand up to
the s p Party Machine take action
um ultimately very loyal to Nicolas
sturgeon still but then there's also the
case I think if Kate Forbes were the
leader of the SMP labor would be
attacking her for her faith for her
views on various social issues and
trying to get the you know some of the
more left-wing SMP voters as a result
Casey thank you very much indeed
now let's turn our attention to America
and the news that Hunter Biden the
president's Troublesome son has accepted
or at least he and his legal team have
accepted a plea bargain that will mean
he is charged uh two on two counts of a
federal tax offense uh and one of on a
gun misdemeanor
um these are relatively light charges uh
say a lot of Republicans compared to
what he could be charged with I'm joined
Now by Charles Lipson who is a professor
of political science at the University
of Chicago and a much-loved spectator
contributor Charles can we start with
the legal side of this what does this
mean for Hunter Biden
well it means he escapes with a slap on
the wrist
the charges uh that uh they seem to have
agreed to are
um light ones and the
um and it's not clear
the the the the
it's clear that he will not serve any
jail time he'll be on probation if the
judge
uh accepts the plea deal the the final
uh decision is always up to the judge
and we don't know who the judge is but
um uh it's likely that the this will be
accepted although there's a possibility
there could be a short uh jail time it's
also worth noting that Hunter's parents
have backed him and that President Biden
has said that he did not interfere in
any way which is not quite true uh
because he made public statements that
he not only supported his son which any
uh decent parent would do but that his
son had done no wrong and therefore uh
as the head of the executive branch and
all of the judicial functions the
prosecutorial functions within it he was
sending a clear message whether that had
any effect we don't know but it is not
true
that he
he uh did nothing it's also worth noting
that the real issue is not whether uh
given these charges he should serve time
in jail it would be perfectly
appropriate for a first-time offender
with these relatively light charges uh
to not spend time in jail although it
would also be appropriate if he did
spend some time in jail the real issues
are whether he could have been charged
with something much more serious
and whether or not in order to get this
plea deal he was required uh to proffer
before
the grand jury and uh the people
Prosecuting him and a profit would be a
complete statement of what he had
actually done and for example he was not
charged with being a a foreign agent
which he could have easily been charged
with and Paul manafort was charged with
and spent time in jail for so uh and
that was the basic uh grift uh the scam
that they were running it wasn't really
a scam they were they were trading off
of his name with foreign entities to get
leverage within the United States
government whether that's a crime or not
it it depends on a lot of things but
it's pretty clear he was acting as
foreign agent and they didn't charge him
with that and it's not clear he
proffered anything he told the grand
jury or told the prosecutors anything
and there is a separate but connected
investigation
um going on that look by the house
oversight committee which is run by
Republicans because they have a majority
in the house into Hunter Biden's
business dealings this has no
relationship this criminal proceedings
has no relationship with with that house
oversight committee does it
no formal relationship but obviously a
political relationship uh viewers
outside of uh uh the United States
should know that because the Republicans
control the House of Representatives
they can send subpoenas that doesn't
mean that the subpoenas have to be
complied with if they come before the
government because if they're not
complied with the House of
Representatives uh would send that
matter over to the Department of Justice
which is controlled by Joe Biden and
they would be unlikely to prosecute but
you can still subpoena Witnesses in the
house in the Senate it would require the
approval of the majority party which is
the Democrats they only control a very
slight majority just as the Republicans
do in the house but they will not
approve any uh subpoenas to look into
the bidens at this point now it may may
be the case that if Joe Biden's
popularity is so low and the Democrats
decide they just have to jettison him
that that they would turn on him but
that hasn't happened yet well and the
the house oversight committee LED as as
I said by Republicans has made it very
clear that they are not going to be put
off by this uh sweetheart plea plea deal
I think uh James Comey called it uh and
and they will pursue
um some quite intriguing uh details that
they have Unearthed uh namely a sort of
bank wire transfer from a Chinese entity
to an associate of the Biden family uh
three months I think it was before after
Joe Biden uh resigned as vice president
in 2017 and they will follow the money
and see where that money went uh do you
think the Biden family the Biden
Administration are despite their
appearances Joe Biden says it's all
Malarkey publicly they are do you think
they are deeply concerned about this
they should be
um the
um the house is uncovering a lot of
information
um that there was a family-wide effort
to monetize Joe Biden's position
um the Democrats position on this is
that if Joe Biden cannot be directly
connected
to any of that then
it's just a matter of family members
trading off of his name which is uh not
illegal I would draw a distinction here
between well there two distinctions one
is something can be deeply corrupt and
not necessarily illegal
and whether that has an implication uh
uh for the body politic is up to what
voters think and that brings us to the
second point which is the the country is
so deeply divided if you look at what uh
and divide it along ideological terms
Britain has been divided along
ideological terms for many decades
because labor and uh and Tori are really
ideologically opposed to each other in a
way that was not true for a long time
between Democrats and Republicans in
America Democrats were more Liberal
Republicans were more conservative but
the the uh ideological differences have
become much deeper and if you show me a
an opinion piece that says
um that this is an appropriate treatment
of Hunter Biden and everything is fair
and hunky-dory uh I can tell you that
was written by a Democrat if you tell me
that it was soft treatment and other
people don't get this kind of treatment
that was written by a Republican
now
that difference no longer applies to
Donald Trump
and that's that's a whole separate issue
we haven't talked about Trump but I
would say that there are a lot of
Republicans that are splitting off
from Trump it's begun with the
intellectual classes the people who
write op-eds and so forth who are deeply
Disturbed some deeply disturbed by
Trump's Behavior some by the fact that
he might not be elected others by the
fact that he might be
and uh so he's a he's a figure like a
Boris Johnson who divides people within
his own party
well a lot of trump people and Trump
himself are crying foul they're talking
about double standards as I suppose you
imagine it would
um and of course there is a difference
between Hunter Biden whose president's
son and Donald Trump who is seeking
re-election he's seeking the Oval Office
again nonetheless uh you can see why I
think even from trying to be as
objective as possible you can see why uh
Trump supporters will look at the legal
persecution of Donald Trump and I think
it's fair to say it's a persecution
because it's happening on so many fronts
and say he could be in jail for the rest
of his life
um for holding on to documents and yet
the president's son has done far more
criminal things it seems uh and is going
to get away without any jail time
that's right but it's also against the
background of Hillary Clinton getting
off all of the uh top people in the FBI
under James Comey
uh the the name Comer uh who is
represent who is the head of the
oversight committee uh is so easy to mix
up but James Comey was the head of the
FBI and uh uh he he was not punished his
top aides were not punished it's very
clear that they misled the Pfizer courts
which are the courts that give these
secret warrants they investigated
um uh Trump for a Russian collusion that
Not only was a hoax but that they should
have known was a hoax they began
investigations according to the person
who investigated all of this John Durham
who is testifying uh before Congress now
uh they began all of this without really
an adequate pretext they clearly went
after Trump and they clearly gave
excuses to people like Hillary Clinton
uh the head of the FBI come Comey wrote
her exoneration before she had been
interviewed
and she had all of these documents on a
Home Server
why was she excused partly because she
was a Democrat say the Republicans but
also because uh President Obama had
communicated with her on that Home
Server and he would have been called as
a witness
her legal team undoubtedly threatened at
any
Court proceeding so she got off and so
for Republicans it begins to look like
all of this is two standards of justice
and for ordinary Americans it looks uh
like if you're connected in Washington
uh whether you're a democrat or a
republican if you're part of the
establishment you get different
treatment than if you're an outsider and
so it's partly
party divisions but it's also Insider
Outsider it's worth remembering
that Trump ran as an outsider indeed as
a former president he's running as an
outsider I'm coming after the Washington
establishment is what he's saying and a
lot of Republicans love that they think
that the Washington establishment uh
doesn't speak for them and that's been
increasingly true as they are governed
we Americans are governed more and more
by bureaucracies who make the rules that
are effectively the laws that govern us
so it's a big problem and
um I would say
there's been a general erosion in trust
in all governmental institutions and the
Department of Justice is uh now in the
Forefront of that people don't trust the
FBI in the way that they used to and
they don't trust the fairness of the
Department of Justice and whenever a
court rules a decision the courts are a
separate branch in America but whenever
the courts rule make a ruling one of the
first things that you see in any
publication is who appointed these
judges was it a Republican or was it a
Democrat well you know that's important
information because it can tell you how
the decision was rendered but it's also
very corrosive to assist to an idea that
we have fair and impartial Blind Justice
a lot of uh the Republicans on this
house committee or or Republicans in the
party and Trump supporters are very keen
to connect Joe Biden to Hunter Biden's
Shady business business activities I
think it's fair to say there's there's
little hints there might have been
something there but there's no Smoking
Gun there's no damning evidence as yet
if no smoking gun or damning evidence
emerges
um do you think this story really hurts
Biden at all or does it actually flip
for him and it becomes gleeful
Republicans uh gloating about this
unfortunate story of an errant sun and
Biden emerges looking like a loving
father
um all his texts to Hunter Biden seemed
to be very supportive he repeatedly says
I love you son and there's obviously a
lot of tragedy in the Biden family uh
Beau Hunter's brother died of brain
cancer
um uh Joe Biden lost his wife and child
in as a in a car crash when the two boys
were small they were both in that car
crash that tragic story is an important
part of Biden's political story I wonder
if it ends up helping him if they can't
find any evidence linking him to the
dodgy activities of Hunter Biden what
always helps to be seen as a loving
father
and the fact that your son has gone
through enormous troubles is something
many Americans can identify with many
people all around the world can identify
with uh but if this goes beyond uh
Hunter and includes other members of the
family for example his brother James uh
the grandchildren got payments we have
no indication that any of them provided
any Services other than opening doors
for people I think that the corruption
is a kind of cloud hanging over Biden
there's an irony here Biden may be one
of the weakest candidates that the
Democrats can put forward
and the irony is that Trump is probably
the weakest candidate the Republicans
can put forward so the attacks by the
other party in a way may may put a
stronger candidate into the lead uh it's
it's hard to know Biden's real problem
nobody can run against uh Biden from the
inside of the party that is a governor
or something like that but it's striking
that a real Outsider with a lot of kooky
views uh the son of the uh former uh
Attorney General Robert F Kennedy and
the nephew of President Kennedy
has gotten up into the 30 percent range
which is not an indication of how much
people like
uh Robert F Kennedy Jr in my opinion
it's an indication of how much they
dislike uh Joe Biden as the candidate
and uh and and yet Biden says he's going
to run and he's running as he did as uh
last time of what's called a basement
candidate see he's not getting out he's
not answering questions because every
time he speaks off the cove
uh he he makes blunders sometimes quite
serious ones and every time he's seen in
public his increasing Frailty uh becomes
a problem and this is a problem for the
Democrats generally because they have
two members of the Senate who look to be
physically and mentally
incapable of performing their jobs
and that gives them the majority they
wouldn't without those two they wouldn't
have the majority now now in in both
cases there are democratic governors of
those two states who could appoint their
successors but uh but it's a problem
that that the Democratic party's
leadership looks increasingly like and
drop off and breshnev in their final
years where they were sort of held up by
other people to do what they're doing
well Charles I could listen to you
talking about Hunter Biden all day but I
think we must end it there sadly uh
thank you very much for coming on to
spectator TV
in The Spectator this week we have
rather a dark feature about stowaways
falling from airplanes onto various
points mostly West London
uh and that piece is written by Louise
Perry the author and broadcaster who
joins me now Louise this is quite a
Macabre topic uh uh it was your idea I
think what Drew you to it
uh I grew up in Sheen right is the is
the simple answer so I Ryan the piece um
in particular about lots of these
um horrible instances of young men
invariably young men
who have stowed away on planes to try
and get to the UK illegally as a place
descend and they've hidden in the the
wheels of the aircraft
um they fall onto the the flight path
essentially and because of how the
Heathrow flight path is is arranged over
a particular suburb of Southwest London
in which I grew up
um an enormous number of them have
fallen in a very very small area of this
suburb so it's sort of a local
phenomenon that is not widely known
about uh and how many what are the
numbers because it's sort of hard to
figure out numbers I mean there's only
sort of recorded I think six instances
of people being caught uh on the planes
in the last 10 15 years
is there any way of estimating how many
people we're talking about this happens
to uh not many yeah not many so you know
maybe one every year or two yeah
um normally as I said in Sheen but the
most recent I think was actually on the
in Clapham on the Gatwick
flight path and it's quite a powerful
symbol as you say in a piece of the
problems of globalization occurring at
the local level
uh is that why when these stories are
reported and sometimes it escalates
Beyond local news into sort of national
Consciousness it they really Grant
people I think people are very struck by
humans falling from the sky it's
horrific it's I mean it's
sort of
um
Vivid representation of
the issue of illegal migration because
in some senses it's sort of similar to
the small boats phenomenon in that it's
invariably young men
um generous from Asian Africa
attempting this very
hazardous journey to get to the UK
except obviously that I mean I mean the
the the stowaway on stowing away on
planes method is attempted less rarely
um because it's invariably fatal
and it also suggests that uh governments
may be able to reduce
migration immigration
but actually that we're quite powerless
given the sheer appetite that there is
among desperate people in the world to
come to Britain yes and I quote in the
piece that the figures that um Gallop
periodically collects
um asking people all across the world if
they could come to the West would would
they want to and an enormous number of
people say yes it's not everyone by any
means but it is an enormous number and
when we have the technology to
facilitate that you know we're with
airplanes and when we have also mass
media kind of broadcasting images of the
affluence of the West all over the world
sort of why wouldn't people want to come
Sheen basically is paved with gold from
the perspective people in many parts of
the world I don't want to get too into
the morbid details of it but what
actually happens in these cases when a
body is found splattered all over the
pavement well not necessarily splattered
I should say first because actually they
like
sorry but they're frozen yeah because of
the nature of the altitude
um so actually they're normally
remarkably well preserved and what has
happened to date is that
uh British State Services of various
kinds have put a lot of effort into
finding out the agencies of these young
men and returning their bodies to their
families if they can
um and you know there have been full
inquests and so on we've kind of set the
whole
State apparatus and train
um to to do the right thing by them
um but you can't really stop occasional
attempts at doing this because we've got
to assume that these young men don't
know that this is a definitely a lethal
yes rude so it's not a case of sort of
uncaring Britain no it just lets these
people drop out of the sky no it's just
I think it's just the nature of global
inequality that people will sometimes
try and do this well it is a very gloomy
but fascinating topic thank you very
much Louise for coming to talk about it
thank you
on Tuesday England lost an absolutely
thrilling test match against Australia
the first of this year's ashes
uh and it's fair to say that England's
team captain by Ben Stokes has come
under a bit of criticism for its very
aggressive exciting style of cricket
which is known as bazball it's a much
mocked term but that's what it's called
bazball
um to discuss this I'm joined by Henry
Bluefield a legendary great commentator
and journalist
uh and Henry I thought I'd start by
before we get into bazball because
that's been talked about a lot this week
I thought I'd just start by saying it's
almost 20 years since the 2005 ashes
which is extraordinary because it seems
to have gone by very quickly
um and that series was the most exciting
of my lifetime uh possibly the most
exciting ever
um do you think we might have as
exciting a test Series this year
well I mean the answer is yes but really
that's an impossible questions it's how
long's a piece of string isn't it really
I mean on the evidence of the first test
match yes but things don't often often
don't work out quite as planned and I
mean it was very very ahead of yourself
and that person wasn't this and if we're
going to get five of those gonna say
what state all of us will be in six
weeks time a beloved thing but quite
honestly let's be realistic if we get
two more uh nothing like that it's going
to be terrific isn't it if we if we were
lucky enough to get five well I mean
it's something that's never happened
before I mean you were talking about
exciting series my most exciting series
was Colin cowardly tour of the West
Indies since 678 uh when four of the
five test matches were absolute but and
there was one dollar one in Barbados but
I mean there we are uh
we will see what happens but stokes's
style of play and this England team's
style of play does make things more
exciting doesn't it
oh enormously so I mean I think what
they've got to do I I'm all about Paul
personally because we're in an age when
um doing these crazy is being put under
great pressure by all these T20
franchises and the T20 cricket on the
scale and I think by playing in this way
in test Cricket two innings Cricket has
become deeply of Desperately exciting
and I think it is so important the two
innings Cricket is kept on the map
because if we'll take it out to the
equation Cricket becomes a a game
perhaps that won't be worth watching in
a few years time because it'll be all
about bottom-handed soggy I mean if it
was only T20 you will never see a fast
further voting again with four steps and
two gullies you'll never see a really
good defensive technique because it's
it's sort of unimportant and you'll
never see those love Dave Strokes like
the late Cuts or the leg blind Lord leg
glances the game would change in
irrevocably and I think there is
um Spectators might fall away well we
should say full Spectators of spectator
TV could you possibly Define basketball
because I'm not sure I've heard a very
good definition yet well I think I think
baseball is simply taking the attack to
the enemy from the first ball I mean we
saw it in this test match when Zach
Crawley drove that Festival from Cummins
uh through the covers and in fact it was
a magnificent blows it did tell a story
uh we saw pasmore and Joe roofs on the
fourth morning he played and the first
ball of the day he did this what they
call a ramp which I think is an awful
name uh when they he'd play the sort of
reverse scoop over the slip's heads a
stroke which Joe root says is as safe as
houses as long as there isn't the third
man which there wasn't and and as a
result of that of playing that stroke
and playing it thrill four more times in
the next two hours the two of the close
fielders went back on the boundary and
then he was able to push the ball around
for singles so actually it was a
tactical Victory what he did then but I
mean then Bruce and the second Innings
uh ran down the Wicket to Lion didn't
get into the right position
cross padded slogan here and was stumped
for the first time in his life in the
first match I mean that was out of
character and actually it was stupid
because root must have known that if
he'd batted another ah the match will
save for England and victory was was was
was very probable that is extraordinary
isn't it that Joe root arguably the best
batsman in the world uh I I think he's
the best bachelor in the world uh he's
he'd never been stumped is that because
he's he's just such a good batsman that
even if he comes down the pitch a lot he
doesn't get stumped
I think he's probably because he plays
spin so frankly well uh modern batsman
as a rule don't play has been very well
simply because they don't get very much
of it but Joe wrote is an exception he
plays it extremely well and I think even
plays pin will don't get stumped I mean
okay you can get stunned off a fast
medium Bell of the week even sounds
close but that's unlikely uh but I think
that is probably the main reason and
also Joe root has got a very level ahead
on him when it comes to Fat uh he didn't
have a very level head on him when he
came to Captain said they didn't have
any hit on him at all half the time as
far as an agency uh but I mean that's
one of the remarkable things about
what's happened to English figures at
the moment is that Stokes and McCallum
have done this with the same people who
were going absolutely nowhere in a hurry
under Joe root I mean that to my mind is
extraordinary but I mean rude himself is
such a good player there's no need for
him to indulge in stupid successes and
and you're probably tired of uh arguing
about it but uh I wanted to ask you
about the Declaration in the first
Innings uh at headingley
I mean Ben Stokes for people that don't
follow create Ben Stokes declared which
means he ended the Innings early with
two wickets to go and England could have
scored some more runs that evening he
put the Australians into bat we did not
take a wicket and now people are looking
back on it and saying that was a
terrible decision if he had taken a week
and everyone even saying it was a window
wouldn't it I mean I mean no it is it's
as simple as that but actually I rather
tend to agree with Rook batting as well
as he did I think in fact my own belief
is that if there had been seven or six
wickets down he would have added on but
there were eight wickets down there was
only abroad and Anderson left and I
think he felt well if we can get a
wicked no it really is going to put the
Aussies on the back foot the Aussies has
shown uh that they were very defensive
when it came to basketball they started
off two deep fielders we just reading
sides have never done before and they
were thrown undoubtedly and I think in
the circumstances it was a legitimate
gamble it didn't come off but I don't
think it mattered
um and and and I think as I say what
didn't come off too was the fact of the
week we didn't really have a very
effective week giver and if Pastor had
been able to stump it was um Greek
hammer and green wasn't it and then had
taken those catches uh we wouldn't be
having this conversation in the way that
we are we're getting one would have won
do you think that dropped catch at the
End by Stokes it was agonizingly uh uh
close to being caught do you think that
was that a key moment for you
well I I yes but I I I I hate to say
that I got soaked handled it pretty well
honestly and I think he did it very well
to get them all into his hand as he as
he did it was unlucky he hit the ground
with his elbow I think it came out I
mean that is life I'm afraid life is the
fast lane you may say playing basketball
but um I don't think I I don't quite
know uh what went wrong in in that last
bit although I have to say I thought
Cummins bad it's simple
I mean the way he came down fearlessly
with with with Australia looking at
defeat and straight PRO root for those
two sixes I thought it was magnificent
and um you you got you got you can't
only look at it from the point of view
of England not winning I think you've
got to look at it from the fact that
Australia in the end got up and won and
that Captain did it for them and so too
don't leave out Nathan lion a wonderful
cricketer
um a bit of doubty opponent and a Wonder
Love speller but then he came in and
batted and he played two strokes of
Anderson he drove him through middle
before and then laid him off his legs
that's why the mid on before more they
were wonderful sharks and you've got to
hand it to him batting at number 10. and
I I think in the end I I didn't I've
Illustrated deserve that Victory
honestly yes they're just a brilliant
team aren't they Cummings is a is a
magnificent uh
but they've got gaps and I think what I
think is my overall righty impression
after the match is that England will get
better because I think they're going to
realize that the basketball has got
rough edges which have got to be
sandpapered down the rough edges that uh
if you like they've got um Joe root out
I mean that's on the thing they've got
not to be stupid with bazball and um and
I think that's what a lot of the
conversation within that
enclosed dressing room or enclosed hotel
rooms will be a boat at the moment I
just think it's we are it's very nearly
perfected this basketball I'm not at all
against it a lot of people I know are
um I I'm not certain why as I said
earlier I think the great thing about
fastball is It's a Wonderful
advertisement for two innings cricket
and that's something that we desperately
need because as I say cricket without
two innings Cricket is not going to be a
game ultimately worth watching uh just
very quickly and lastly uh Henry uh you
you would not uh let bearsto be
wicketkeeper no I wouldn't they're going
to have him Vlogs I gather I personally
would have uh brought folks in absence
right away because
um it's it's getting a bit tight Cricket
Lords is a difficult ground to keep
working on I kept wigging down myself
and I'm not okay pretend that I didn't
Des match I didn't but the slope at
Lords means that if you're giving away
that the Pavilion end and the ball goes
down the offsides or right hand or all
the leg side to a left-hander a week he
was going to go anything up to a yard
and a half further to his right because
the ball goes on down the step and
Ambassador doesn't move anywhere I mean
he was you saw how dead and footed He
was when um kawaja sneaked his second
ball in the second Innings and he went
for four between root and bears though
not a cat's Rook because first lip
stands further back from the keeper and
the weak Giver had to go for it and and
folks record that I'm sure
um it was a week he gave his catch I
mean Alan Knox would have had a bit had
he seen that one and perhaps he was
watching in Cyprus where he lived isn't
that a bit there I don't know and I I
said last question last question but I
do want to squeeze one more in uh and
it's probably a question you won't like
but will you make a prediction as to
what will happen in this series
yes I will I I personally think that
England will get up and will win it will
win a very narrow victory in the series
I'm not going to start saying free two
or two ones I have no idea but I I have
this belief that England will improve on
that performance because I think they
will see the Folly of their ways the one
thing I put against that is we got
lavish in and Smith out sheep there
twice and they're going to contribute at
some stage uh I'm not certain that
either are quite as good as they were
but and Broad is bowling very well
indeed but equally against that we've
got five test matches in six weeks is he
going to be able to stand the pace will
he need a rest who knows there are an
awful little ifs and hands aren't they
but my own feeling is that England will
win a very narrow victory in the series
well the IPS and hands make it uh
thrilling uh Henry thank you so much for
coming on spectator TV it's it's a great
honor to have you on and I should say
you are much missed as your commentary
on on test match special is much missed
by everybody I know certainly well I
think lots of people if their wound
scares were dropped on their heads as
babies
very much too but
um anyway I'm not sure I'll just do it
now
that's it for this week thank you very
much for watching a reminder to
subscribe to this program if you don't
already you do that by clicking the
button at the bottom of your screen and
then click the Bell icon to make sure
you never ever miss an episode and I
should give a final thank you to our
brilliant sponsors Kenneth called
genuity wealth management canacord will
provide you with the expertise you need
to help you build your wealth with
confidence visit can do wealth.com for
more information
okay That's all folks thanks very much
for watching
[Music]